okay new strategy don't ruin it too much
I am gonna be cutting Steve's hair today
I am nervous that I'm gonna cut too much
of his hair off and he's gonna be mad at
me a short Jake Gyllenhaal type style
this is what I picked out for Tyler's
ideal haircut I think we can pull this
off
I am pretty like particular about my
hair very pretty I get pretty stressed
out I've been going to the same barber
now for 3 years so as long as it doesn't
look like complete then I'll be okay
with it plus I've got a couple of new
hats I'm looking forward to wearing I'm
not gonna get mad at her unless you does
a bad job focus all right Jen you gonna
pick it up I think I like this no no you
got it you gotta pick it up look inside
okay you don't just shoot in there it's
not an arts and crafts project I feel
like if I were to pursue a different
career pick a few hair I'm glad that you
feel so casual about this if your baby
are you ready for the scoop oh no no
hold on we really got a game plan this
one this what you're gonna do you're
gonna like get the fingers out and
you're gonna slice their hook you've
been spending a little too much time on
the left side is that just me I don't
know I shouldn't be directing you you're
the one who can see what's going on here
I haven't been this dressed to get a
haircut since I was like three well she
stopped laughing that's either good or
bad is oh my god
[Music]
there's just like one small vault no
there's not
there are balls it's nothing happens so
you know how surgeons are trained to
like when they mess up stay there mind
if I start doing it looking good
you know you've said I look good way too
much for me to believe that you actually
feel that way yeah I think I'm done this
is the Jake Gyllenhaal courtesy of yours
truly
okay it's not okay it's not that bad
[Music]
this is know that I was expecting so
much worse
so thank you it's actually kind of dopey
I mean like it is aside it's not very
good
okay fine but it's not that what
[Music]
I don't think I should ever cut his hair
ever again it's too stressful
and if I had done any worse I think we
would have got into a fight would I let
you cut my hair again let's just say not
in the next a long time there I look
there's one of those kids that just back
bubble gum seconds here and there's like
we gotta get it out any way possible you
know but I think it looks cool let me
I'll grow into it